hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar how to translate a t-reg cell
research workflow to clinical grade
manufacturing
i am marie stone of lab labroots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by miltoni biotek
to learn more visit miltonibbiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
nilofar monahaseri
global products manager for t-cell
immunology miltoni biotek now afar you
may now begin your presentation
hello everyone my name is nilu
pharmanhasseri i'm the product manager
for immunology t cells at milton biotech
and in
this webinar for today i'm going to
explain you how to translate a two-week
research workflow to clinical grade
manufacturing
so let's start the agenda for today
first of all i would like to give you an
introduction about miltoni biotech and
then talking about t-rex
and then following the webinar by
talking about two reg research workflow
and then to a clinical grade workflow
and end up to the summary and final
remarks
miltoni biotech was founded at 1989
in germany
we are more than
3500 employees all over the world from
more than 50 nationalities
and 25 persons of our employee are
working at r d and we are reported in
more than uh
46 000 scientific references
we have more than
17 000 products and presents in more
than a hundred thousand cell therapy
procedures and also
uh approximately six thousand patients
treated with cell products using our
technologies and uh
we have uh
sales direct sales in 23 countries and
we are transporting our products to more
than 73 countries as well
miltoni biotech is empowering discovery
and advancing therapy our mission is to
advance scientific research and medicine
by providing solutions for curative cell
and gene therapy as well as biomedical
research we have wide variety of product
portfolio and our products are from
research to clinical applications
in miltoni biotech we are covering
different topics such as immunology
cancer research stem cell research
cardiovascular research and neuroscience
and at the same time in the clinical
side we have very great uh portfolio for
graft engineering immune therapy and
also regenerative medicine
okay let's start with some introduction
about t
translating t-reg research to clinical
application
regulatory t-cells 2x are very important
subset of t cells and they have three
main functions the first one is
suppression of overwhelming immune
responses which keep the balance and
homostasis in the body the second
important functions is suppression of
immune responses against self-antigens
and non-self antigens which protect
against autoimmunity and mediate the
tolerance in the body and the third
functionality of two eggs is suppression
of anti-cancer immune responses which
support the tumor growth and it's a
functionality that needed to be
considered especially during the
cancer treatment as um
two eggs in this area are supporting the
tumor growth and their functionality
needed to be controlled actually
and um recognition of the regulatory
t-cells as you might know t-rex are not
expressing any unique like surface
markers they can be recognized or
phenotypes by fun by a combination of
the surface markers such as cd4 cd25
lack of cd127
or
cd45ra
and so on and the uh very important
intracellular markers it's fox p3
that
expression of this transcription shows
the functionality of this uh the t-rex
and also according to their um origin of
this
two rags they can subdivide it in three
groups naive t-rex peripheral t-rex and
in vitro 2x
t-rex can be a studies in different
research and clinical fields and
in different indications like
transplantation inflammation allergy
cancer gvhd autoimmune disease pregnancy
and so on but why 2x has really like key
roles in the body because as you can see
this illustration there is a balance
between two regulatory cells and t
effector cells in a situation that the
body is in a healthy condition
but in some circumstances this balance
is disturbed antioch therapy
is going to uh
really like protect
this balance and then retain this
balance so by expanding the two eggs and
infusion to the patient they try to keep
this balance again re-establish this
balance again let's say so it's the
reason that two ectropy is an important
uh part of adaptive immune therapy and t
cell therapy
and for
all these research areas and clinical
studies
you need to have good and optimized
workflow in the research side and in the
clinical side and it's our mission to
provide enough tools for you to achieve
your goals
so let's go one step further and have a
look at t-reg research workflow at
miltoni biotech
t-rex workflow consists of different
steps
sample preparation cell separation
expansion and cell analysis
and as i've mentioned at the beginning
of my talk at miltoni we are offering
translational workflows and 2x is one of
the topic that we are covering
completely translational workflow
from research products which i'm gonna
show in orange color that's our sort of
products for human mouse and non-private
and as you can see in this
photo or slides we cover all these steps
of a workflow and at the same time we
have some sort of gmp products that
cover the clinical workflow i'm going to
talk about each steps
in the following slides
okay let's start with research portfolio
and the first step is sample preparation
for getting a very good result out of
your whole experiment you need to
optimize your sample preparation
the main resources of two eggs in mouse
are spleen and lymph node and also it
can be isolated from tumor and other
various tissue
and
in human uh we can isolate two eggs
mainly from pvmcs directly from blood
blood and also from tumor and other
tissues but in the sample preparation
platform
um
we are focusing on the uh tumor and
tissue uh material and
gentle max dissociator
big family
tissue dissociation kits and all the
solutions that you need to um
store your cells remove your dead cells
and different type of tubes and also
strainers and filters that can help you
to get a very high quality
cell suspension with high viability are
available in our
sample preparation platform
i'm pretty sure that many of you know
about gentlemax but i really want to
emphasize on this great device and tell
you that it is really like i always say
that it is the heart of the sample
preparation part because it provides a
standardized tissue dissociation and
you really save your samples as the
dissociation can be done in closed
system and it's one instrument for both
cellular and molecular applications and
there are some optimized protocol for
the most frequently used tissue and at
the same time customized programming for
any type of tissue is possible in this
device and we offering you comprehensive
kits for enzymatic treatments that is
adopted and addressed in this device as
well
and
we are offering elaborate strainers and
filters to get a single cell suspension
and remove the debris and cell clumps
and all and all ended to very high
quality with high viability of single
cell suspension
let's have a look at the
application example that was done with
one of our customers they use a gentle
max dissociator and also um gentle maxi
tube
besides using 70 micrometers smarter
strainer and then they try to um
dissociate the mouse dorsal skin which
is a hard tissue to
uh dissociate and then they identified
fox p3 positive regulatory t cells as
you can see here the total number of
these cells uh was compared with manual
protocol and gentle max protocol in
gentle max protocol you see that you
have less
variation and in the next graph you can
see the reasonable and really like high
difference between the cd4 positive fox
p3 positive two eggs
out of gentle max
in comparison to
manual protocol which shows the good
efficiency of this device and
combination of the products to
dissociate the tissue and also in this
uh
right hand side you can see the fox p3
cells which were analyzed with fellow
cytometry that's
the gentlemax protocol showed a higher
cell number of pox p3 positive cells
compared to the manual protocol
okay the next step t-reg isolation you
need to choose the best strategy to
isolate your t-rex at miltoni biotech we
offer you wide variety of products and i
know that sometimes you say
which one is really fitting to our
workflow and how can i get a high purity
high
let's say recovery and so on and so on
and some of you have very like a
specific needs in your workflow but i
can tell you they have the max cell
separation magnetic suppression
technology
that offers you different type of
like kits
and we offer different and wide variety
of the devices from very manual devices
to fully automated robotic integration
devices
and beside all these separation kits
we are going to offer you t-rex starting
with our unique quantity to cell sorters
i'm going to talk about each of these
options step by step
here you are
max cell separation select the best we
are offering you wide variety of
products for example
for positive selection which is really
ideal for rare cells and hard to process
tissues
or untouched selection with isolation
kits that is really like a good approach
for pre-enrichment before fellow
analysis or subsequent positive
selection or max express solutions for
really being fast and easy and
convenient and at the same time you can
scale cell separation according to your
needs you can benefit from completely
manual approaches or benefit from
multi-max x for fully automated system
in maxwell separation columns are a
technological advantage max column
amplifies the magnetic field by 10 000
times
and the cells get minimal labeling with
nano size microbeads and also
cells friendly hydrophilic coating
and large space between steel spheres in
column metrics are provided
and then you will enrich your cells
without any
on a specific activation the cells has
like free epitopes for downstream uh
compatibility
and also there is no beat
aggregation as you can see in the
picture as well and this method is can
be easily translated to um clinic and it
can be a scalable and automatable
according to your needs and also this
technology is using clinical researchers
for cell manufacturing in in more than
55 000 patients and it is approved by
fda
at miltoni biotech we are offering you
wide variety of products for isolating
your t-rex i know that sometimes it
makes it really difficult for you to
choose the best kit and a strategy for
isolating yourselves so please stay with
me i'm going to explain you about all
the strategy then you can choose the
best one for your research
first of all i would like to start with
max express t-rex isolation kits which
enable you to isolate your t-rex
directly from the whole blood
max express t-rex isolation kit helps
you to isolate your t-rex directly from
blood
in this approach your cells get labeled
and then depletion of non-cd4 positive
cells can be done and it followed by
taking the supernatants and then
positive selection for
cd25 can happen and at the end the cells
can be eluted
uh in the final buffer
so in this approach you will isolate
your 2x just in 30 minutes which is
quite fast the current solution other
kids takes longer than 90 minutes
and then you will get a excellent purity
of the cells as you can see here 90
percent cd4 cd25 positive cells and over
60 percent fox tree cells
and also the uh recovery uh out of this
kit is quite good so turret can be
isolated from whole blood without phycol
and it's one of the options for the
teams that
time is a real matter for them they want
to get
the best purity and recovery in a very
short time
let's continue with other kids that's uh
help you to isolate your tubex from pbmc
some of them are just for human some of
them for human and mice let's have a
look in the next slide you will see that
how efficient each of them are working
and how they fit in your
workflow
all the turret isolation kits based on
two steps depletion of unwanted cells
and positive selection
and i put here cd4 cd25 positive
two-back isolation kit as an example in
the first step
at actually the depletion of unwanted
non-cd4 positive cell can be done and
you will have untouched target cells and
in the next step you will have the
positive selection of cd
um 25 positive cells as you can see
years
the untouched cells get labeled and then
they pass through to the magnet and then
the captured cells can be eluted to the
final buffer and you will have your
final cd4 city 25 positive 2xls
okay let's have a look at this busy
slide the first question is what do you
need you really need to
understand your application and why do
you need your two eggs and what is your
downstream application when you can
answer this question then you can have a
look at the different kits and then the
different purity that you can get from
each kids and also the recovery out of
each kids for example if you are going
for highest purity of the fox p3
positive cells
like up to 96 percents and isolate your
naive two eggs i would
uh advise you to use cd4 city 25 city
127 theme kits
or if you are really going for
isolation of naive t-rex but you want to
expand them in long term in vitro so i
would suggest you to use cd4 city city
49 negative turret isolation kits
so as i've mentioned first of all we
need to understand why do you need your
t-rex what is your downstream
application and then we can help you to
choose the best strategy and the best
kit for your workflow
okay in this slide i put some data for
you that i know that you will like it it
shows the functionality of cd4 cd25
positive
cd127 team negative turret isolation
kits
the uh
fellow analysis shows that we can reach
over 92 percent cd4 cd25 positive cells
and also over 90 percents of cd4 cd25
positive cd100 2017 negative cells and
in the negative fraction you will see
that the
ratio of the
city for city 45 racd 127 dim negative
cells is not that much high and it's to
be honest it's by one of my favorite
isolation kits that helps you to really
reach high purity with a very good
recovery and also enables you to isolate
your naive t-rex that
you can expand for a long time in the
culture as well
two eggs can be isolated via cell sorter
as well and here i would like to use
this opportunity to talk about max
quantile cell sorter many of you are
already in the t-rex field and know
about this great device as it is a
translational device and you can use it
in research on clinical sites it's just
one aspect of this device but this
device is quite gentle
to the cells then it helps you to reach
high viability of the cells it contains
three lasers for up to 10 optical
parameters and also it's fully enclosed
disposable cartridge for sample as
reality and operator system and you will
get a very great viable cells that
enables you to go for whatever
downstream application that you need
maxcon title cartridges are an important
component of this system they have three
chambers input chambers positive
selection chambers and negative
collection chambers
in the positive collection chambers you
will get your positive fraction any
negative collection chamber you will
have the negative
uh let's say um
sort of cells and then in the negative
fraction you can even use them for the
second round of
selection and as you can see the
microchip is located here on the bottom
of the cartridge and you can see the
size of this microchip which is quite a
small
and also the maximum volumes for the
input is 10 milliliter positive
collection chamber
can contain 2 milliliters and then
negative collection chambers
uh 10 milliliter and as you can see here
distorting this wall is um
it's the wall that just uh direct the
negative fraction to the negative
chamber and positive um fraction to the
positive chamber and here are located
these three lasers that help the cells
to be sorted
accordingly
in this slides you can see an example of
sorting of memory t-rex
to get the memory t-rex we stain the
cells with cd4 cd25
cd127 cd45r0
and
cd45ra
fluorescence colors and then we sorted
the cells and the target cells you can
see for cd4 positive cd24 25 positive
cells will reach up to uh sorry over to
95 percent
and uh like if two eggs will reach like
97
and the memory t-rex um fraction is
really great number like over 98 percent
uh purity and it shows the functionality
of these um
this uh cell searcher for sorting even
like the very very rare cells with the
highest purity that you can get
t-rex expansion i know that this step
can be very challenging but with
choosing the best component for your
tourette culturing you can optimize this
step
maxwell
culture media
offering you tex max medium which is a
special medium for
expansion of t cells and also t-rex they
are free of animal drive component they
are offering optimal cell growth
reliable activation and also
um
are available with or without fennel
reds and uh they are available up to gmp
qualities especially um attractive for
the teams that has like translational
plan to translate their research studies
to their clinical studies the second
component is the choosing the good
cytokines we offer you max cytokines and
premium grade which has
improved sequence that offer you better
reconstitution and increase stability
and activity in the culture and also
they are available for human and mouse
cell simulation
they give you a lot of specific
biological activity and also they are
available up to gmp quality
the next component is expansion kits
which
help you to simulate your 2x to get the
best
let's say expansion they have these
expansion kits for human and mouse and
also these expansion kits are available
to gmp quality
in this slide i would like to show you
with some data the efficacy of these
components all together
uh okay we decided to isolate the t-rex
with different isolation kits and we did
that and then we cultured the cells in
tex-max medium
in the presence of ielts ii premium
grade drapomycin and the simulation kits
or expansion tear kits and i just
decided to show you the expansion rate
of the two eggs out of max express t-rex
isolation kits
after 14 days we reached 22 times
expansion
and after 21 day we reached 40
times
expansion rate which is a great number
but it is not the end of the story your
cells need it to be really functional
cells
you can test the functionality of your
cells with some like um
functional assays but at the same time
it's really important to check for the
expression of fox p3 to get the most
inhibitory cells in your final yield and
as you can see here over 67 percents of
the expanded souls are positive for fox
p3 cells which is a great uh results
okay at this point i want to stop with
uh talking about qreg research workflow
and wants to start
with the turret clinical grade workflow
and at the end of this step i'm going to
talk about cell analysis as well because
the cell analysis or two reg analysis
platform for two week research workflow
and to a clinical workflow is more or
less similar then i would talk about it
at the end of the turret clinical grade
workflow
i hope that you can remember this slide
as i've mentioned we are a translational
company and we have solutions for the
research studies and clinical studies we
already covered the research side but as
i've mentioned i'm going to talk about
cell analysis at the end
and then i want to start with the um
clinical grade 2 egg manufacturing and
our solutions for you so let's start
there are three main steps for clinical
t-reg manufacturing t-reg isolation
turret expansion and turret analysis and
as you can see here i've sorted all the
needed material that you might need for
producing clinical grade t-rex
i'm going to talk about each step in the
following slides
for clinical grade t-rex manufacturing
we are offering you to workflow but
these two workflows are different just
in 2x isolation step
in the fork flow 1 you can see that
clinimax plus is the main device that
you can deplete cd8 and cd19 cells and
also enrich the cd25 cells and this uh
step can be followed by cell sorting
with a max quantitative cell sorter that
for getting a higher purity even
but in workflow 2 we have cleaning max
prodigy lp 25 process which consists of
three steps enrichments of cd25 cells
labeling the two eggs with
fluorochromes and elute the t-rex
entitled
cell sorter buffers and then the cells
pass through the to the max quantity
cell sorter for reaching the very high
purity cells
okay i would like to give you more info
about this part as i know this step is
really like challenging for lots of you
and you know and you're very like
interested to know more about it
workflow one which is a t-rex isolation
with cleaning max
plus uh it's a specifically a proper
approach for producing cells for for
example gvhd prevention and treatments
and suitable for the application that we
need to reach intermediate to high
purity
and you can reach like
less than 96 percent 2x and these
manufacturing times um or better to say
the isolation steps takes seven hours
and you can expand yourselves according
to your application from 12 to 36
days but there are difference like a
workflow different approaches that you
need to see which approach and which
method for expansion of your cells is
fitting
best to your application
and final cell numbers depending on the
donor and the expansion time
absolutely it's the first but we expect
to get like 50 to 1000 times expansion
as i've already mentioned in clinimax
plus
you can deplete your cells
cd8 and cd19 cells and also in reach
cd25 cells and we have all the reagents
in gmp grade
and afterwards it can be followed by
cell sorting to get a higher purity
but in these um
graphs you can see that you can reach
like over 92 persons purity or target
cells city 25 positive city 127 team
okay clinimax
plus device offers you
different aspects like convenient
isolation process
very high recovery high cell number
yield and maintenance of t-rex phenotype
maintenance maintenance of turret
function and also polyclonal isolation
and we have a reference list as well
that you can use and see which teams are
using this system and how efficient it's
working but what is interesting at this
point
is that there are two main
questions in the field right now that's
how to isolate different 2x subsets or
antigen specific 2x and how to reach the
ultra purity 2x because of some
application right now in the market that
uh many of you need to really reach
ultra pure 2x cells and at the same time
isolate your
antigen-specific 2x or very rare 2x
subsets so what is our solution for this
step
okay the challenges in the market naive
t-rex is a small cell population and i
know that many of you need to isolate
the naive t-rex for downstream
applications ultra pure t-rex is another
challenge that um
lots there are lots of like opportunity
for sorting the cells but they are quite
stressful for the cells and as i've
mentioned at the beginning of my talk
t-rex are quite fragile cells so the
quality of the cells after the um cell
sorting is not really uh the proper one
and also gmp grade flow starting is
needed and it is missed actually right
now but
we as a tool provider offering you two
devices
clinimax prodigy with lp 25
pre-enrichment process and maxcon title
cell sorter which gives you this
opportunity to isolate different tyrix
subsets and reach ultra pure turret
populations
so let's have a look on the
following slides and see how these
devices can help you to
reach your goals
cleaning max prodigy lp25 process
enables you to enrich your cd25
cells and at the same time help you to
label your t-rex with the proper proper
fluorochromes and then i elude your
t-rex in a special buffers that can be
transported to the max quantitative cell
sorter and then you can start sort your
cells to isolate the subpopulation
that you want to reach and also reaching
ultra p or 2x
and this application
uh is mainly used for autoimmune
diseases for
producing car turrets in organ
transplantation you need to really
isolate a specific antigen specific uh
t-rex and reaching ultra-pure t-rex gvhd
and in summary it's really suitable for
application which need ultra-p or t-rex
subset and in this
approach you can reach over 98 percent's
purity
and
the
isolation part takes like about 10 hours
and expansion as well as i've mentioned
in the previous case as well it depends
really to your protocols and which
approach you want to use and what is
your downstream application and how much
you need to expand yourself and it can
be vary from 12 to 36 days and the final
cell numbers it's again dependent on the
donor and expansion time but it's
normally needed to really reach 50 times
2 000 times
expansion
as far as title cell sorter is one of
the very uh well-known device for
sorting of t-rex in t-rex therapy field
i would like to talk about it more again
and emphasize on this device and
the
beneficial points and the advantages of
the device that you can really use in
your workflow you can
use title cell sorter with gmp grade
cartridges
to reach really like a trial and close
system
no carryover or cleaning is needed it's
plug and play
easily scalable no droplets or
detectable oral cells and sample is
never lost and all can be done in the
cartridges
okay i would like to talk about the
capacity of the cartridges which i know
is really important in the clinical
applications as you have more samples
and you need to save your times and also
be flexible with different volume of the
cells
here i would like to show you that we
have one standard cartridge and the
other model of the cartridge is high
speed cartridge and it's it's an
amazing let's say cartridge that helps
you to save your time especially when
you have high volume of the
sample to start and look liquid flow is
in a standard cartridge for four
milliliters in
an hour but in high speed uh cartridge
you can analyze eight milliliter per
hour is the samples and inputs for both
of them are 10 milliliter and maximum
cell
concentration in a standard cartridge is
50 million per ml and also in high speed
cartridge but what is different is
maximum cell flow rate that in the
standard cartridges you can analyze 55
000 cells per second whereas in higher
speed cartridges you can analyze 110 000
cells per seconds and as you know and
you can see here you can really like
save times in this way for example in
each sort for in standard cartridge
takes like 2.5 hours whereas in higher
speed cartridge 1.25 hour
per sorting it might takes a time
and regarding to the uh t-rex sorting as
they are rare cells and you need to
start with really like high volume of
these samples i can imagine that
high-speed cartridge fits perfectly into
your workflow
another aspects of max quantity cell
sorter which is uh which makes it really
fitting into clinical setting is that
sorting happened exclusively in the
fully closed and as trial
cartridges and there is no fluids inside
the instruments itself and also
currently it is approved for 10
different clinical trials phase 1 and 2
and over 200 patient samples sorted with
a title cell sorter and also all the
consumable are available in gmp
grade max gmp grade and all the
extensive documentation are available
for all
that touches the cells and we provide
you um max gmp titral cartridges max gmp
title running buffers and the last but
not the least that i know might be very
attractive for you is max gmp
fluorescence antibody that we have a
very optimized and complete panel of
antibodies for starting 2x
in this slide i would like to share some
data with you to show you the efficacy
of maxclan title soul sorter in starting
the naive 2x
on the left-hand side you can see the uh
analysis of the cells which are
post-product glp-25 process pre-title
cell sorting that in this
graph it shows that we reached 38
percent pre-enrichment of the t-rex
it was followed by debulking uh
sorting and
max quantitative cell sorter and we
reached 83 person's uh purity
but as far as we need higher purity or
go for ultra pu two eggs we started
another sort of uh purity sorting
and the final yield shows you that we
reach 98 percent's uh pure naive t-rex
which you can see are positive city 25
and negative for city hundred
twenty-sevens
t-reg expansion again in the clinical um
great t-rex expansion as well there are
lots of challenges
miltoni biotech is offering you a
customized solution to automate your
workflow you need to ask our customized
application cap team to design a proper
process for you otherwise we have some
sort of products that helps you to
expand yourself but if you want to
benefit from automation in a closed
system you can contact us and ask for
customized application and our
application people are ready to help you
okay two bag expansion as well in a
clinical grade needed some component
that i would like to talk about them in
the following slides
i have already talked about
tex-max medium
in the research site but as i've
mentioned we have the gmp medium grade
as well which contains pharmaceutical
great human serum albomine and it has
optimized formulation vidor without
fennel and it has qc functionality tests
and every batch and it's uh filled in
flexible bags as well or you can ask for
customized formats um and according to
your request our team property
proper format for you but don't forget
that it is really specialized for
optimal cultivation of human t-cells and
2x
okay you need definitely three more
components to reach very good expansion
of your t-rex max gmp expect 2x bits
it's a simulatory bits that help you to
expand your 2x
and it maintain foxp tree expression in
your cells
max gmp rapamycin that you need to use
to inhibit expansion of the conventional
t cells and also to enhance the
proportion of expanded 2x fox p3 cells
in culture
and also max gmp ielts you that you can
see the functionality of this max gmp um
great
cytokines compared to the other
commercial products as
well in these slides i would like to
show you um some like application data
you can see that after
sorting of your cells and title cell
sorter in this experiment will reach
92.7
fox p3 positive cells
and cd25 positive cells
14 days culturing in tex max gmp medium
max gmp expect t-rex kit in the presence
of rapamycin and gmp il2
you reach
98.3 positive uh persons positive cells
for fox p3 and cd25 but don't forget
that t-rex expansion
is really donor dependent and depending
to the fact that you are using the
healthy or patient samples depending on
your manual protocols and depending on
the duration of the expansion
and all the components that are present
in the culture play a key role on the
expansion rate of your t-rex
for t-rex analysis you can analyze your
tuberics functionally or phenotypically
and there are some key markers that you
need to
uh analyze them during an the the
phenotypical analysis and for functional
analysis we have a specific turret
suppressor inspector kit
to analyze your cells uh properly you
need to use a good
let's say
fellow cytometry uh device we offer you
max quant analyzer family with different
um definitions and models and i don't
want to really talk about all of them in
the details but just to informing you
that we are offering you a big family of
the uh max quan's analyzer with
different uh specification
for phenotypical analysis of t-rex we
have some t-rex detection kit which are
optimized antibody kits with hydrated or
let's say pre-titrated antibodies
developed as a simple one reagent
solution and at the same time you can
benefit from re-affinity recombinant
antibody plus our biodie antibody
conjugation which offers you high purity
and lots to lost consistency for greater
reproducibility and you can eliminate a
tedious and costly fc receptor blocking
steps because they have one universal
isotope which control
for the convenience and cost saving
and here i would like to tell you that
we can help you to analyze your cells
phenotypically with very
optimized and
flexible panel of antibodies you just
need to contact us
and say
your aim your goal your wish panel and
we help you to optimize your panel
here i can show you like a t-rex surface
marker detection using an eight color
panels we can help you to even
do the correct gating and designing the
proper panel for your
specific needs and also staining the
intra cellular markers and surface
markers and then the cells from
different resource cells
and also you can analyze the
functionality of your
t-rex and t-rex suppression and spectra
is a polyclonal stimulus that are maxi
beats coupled to alpha cd3 cd28 and cd2
these maxi bits coupled that coupled
with this alpha cd3 cd28 and cd2 they
assimilate your responder t cells in an
optimized way that they can chlorifrate
as you can see here in this illustration
their cells the responder cells
got their simulation
and they spa expanded but in this uh
part they got the simulation but as far
as the t responder cells are
co-culturing with t-rex and the t-rex
are functional they didn't let the two
responder cells to
be polarified and in this way you can
analyze the functionality of your cells
i really wish for longer time to show
you more application examples and cover
all the aspects of the workflow and all
the
solutions that we have for each steps
but please reach out to us to get more
information at this time i have to
really go to the summary part and
just finish my talk
if you need more information on our web
page you can find our clinical and
research brochures we have different
application note references list we have
like different type of scientific
posters macs and more
like some
customer reports and you can have a look
at
the application page for the research
regulatory t cells clinical application
of regulatory t cells and getting lots
of information about different devices
that i was talking during my talk and
don't hesitate to contact us the local
team and global team directly to get
more information in each step of your
workflow
and with this disclaimer i would like to
finish my talk and say that i'm so
thankful for your attention your
participation and i'm waiting for your
feedback and getting your
questions again thank you so much for
your attention and i'm ready to answer
your questions
thank you
nilafar for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
what do you mean
about translating from research to
clinical
are the products the same
it looks like we might be having some
connection issues here
let me see
bear with us for just a minute
um
my apologies for the interruption um our
spiegel speaker will be joining us
shortly
um and then we will we will start the
questions
um once they're back in sorry i'm back
okay
all right so our first question is
what do you mean about translating from
research to clinical are the products
the same
it's a really good question i received
this question very often um
our products are not really identical
they are similar
but the main point is that we need to
really
set up our experiment in smaller scales
and get some like optimization and get
some results which is basis of your
next action which might be translated to
your clinical so you need to really um
get familiar to analyze your cells and
expand your cells for example expansion
of two eggs is can be very challenging
so it's really help you to optimize your
workflow in a smaller scale and as soon
as you think that your confidence and
you have like long-term plans to move to
clinic you can start to
use the clinical products and optimize
the clinical
workflow as well but for example
regarding 2d cell separation i've
received lots of question that if we can
use this separation and the isolation
kits for the clinical application as
well
you know that you need to reach some
standards and you need to know that you
need to work in a trial situation you
need gmp format products and with all
these um clinical devices clinical
reagents uh with all this uh really like
um complete documentation we help you to
um produce clinical grade products
and um
the products are working in the same
with the same technology for example
regarding to the isolation the isolation
kits are using the uh max column
technology and in the we in the clinical
side as well you benefit from the same
technology
but you cannot use really absolutely not
the uh
research products for clinical
manufacturing and after a while you
really need to move through to
um clinical products and optimization of
your um
clinical workflow
great thank you
next question
if you want to pick a kit to isolate the
naive t-reg with high purity and
recovery which kit would you suggest
i think i've mentioned that during my
talk but i just repeat that um i think
with cd4 cd25 positive
cd127
kit
you really
can isolate the naive t-rex with a very
good purity and recovery
and it was tested with different
customers they are really happy with
that but you should keep in your mind
when you want to go for naive g-rags for
sure you are looking for more rare cell
types and your recovery might be lower
because um sometimes i just hear that
okay with this city for city 25 we reach
a better p which uh better recovery why
we cannot reach that recovery with the
other kids because with cd4 cd25 kid you
reach um really like general t-rex you
know but with the city 2017 kit you
reach a
more pure naive t-rex and the cells out
of this isolation kits
are really expanding good in the
in-house in hand of the customers other
customers and i would
highly recommend this product to choose
thank you
next question why do you recommend the
use of rapamycin i get a gus gut
expansion without it
yes rapamycin
is not really affecting the growth rate
it is affecting the purity of the cells
or not saying purity but the quality of
your cells at the end
it
really inhibits the expansion of the
conventional t-cells that we we
really don't want to have them in the
final yield you know because the
expansion rate might be similar when you
just use it or either
not use this um
rapamycin but the
final yield uh has a better quality and
i mean that in a sense that um you have
more suppressory qx and you inhibit the
expansion of conventional t-cells
thank you next question is it possible
to use title sorting after isolation of
the cells with clinimax plus
yes i think you can
and we have
and there are some like teams in the
field that are sorting their cells after
um
enrichments of the cells with clinimax
plus it's possible but when we are
talking about
clinimax prodigy lp 25 process it gives
you another level of like flexibility
and automation in a sense that you can
label your cells in an automated closed
system with your fluorochromes and then
isolate them directly in the buffer i
mean that this labeling and
dilution in the title buffer is
automated and in a closed system so it
is the reason that we highly
recommend to use this sort of automation
closed system and um yes but in general
yeah it is possible to use clinimax plus
to enrich cells and then using title
cell sorted but labeling of the cells in
the middle needed to be done manually
and it's not included in the process on
clinimax floss
thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
do you have any solution for t-reg
expansion atomization
yes we have the solution as i've
mentioned we have this captain
customized application team that's you
need to contact them talking about your
application your needs which steps you
want to really include and
how long you want to expand yourselves
and so on and so on and then they help
you and design a process customized
process just for your need
that fits good into your application but
in general right now we don't have any
like a standard process on prodigy or
any other devices that
automize the expansion of the two eggs
thank you nilafar do you have any final
comments for our audience
no thank you so much for your attention
and please feel free to contact us the
local team the global team we are here
to help you
great well thank you again nilafar for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor
miltoni biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye